mitten in der nacht kommt der impfstoff
an auf der kleinen insel kinos nach zehn
stunden fahrt von athen
was hier unter polizeischutz
transportiert wird reicht um die gesamte
inselbevölkerung zu impfen gegen das
corona virus auf einmal am nächsten
morgen kimonos wartet auf offiziell 910
einwohner leben hier die ersten stehen
schon an der im station die ersten
nummern werden aufgerufen nummer 102
bürgermeister constantinus wintour ist
schaut ob es auch läuft wann hast du
deinen termin
ich bin erst am 13 aber ich dachte
lieber mal hingehen aus sorge der
impfstoff reicht nicht was genau es ist
genug für alle da es ist bereits die
zweite dosis die sie erhalten und zwar
alle bürger direkt hintereinander weg
gut vorbereitet das ganze besser als in
athen finden sie hier
154 personen bis jetzt gut dann
erreichen wir unser ziel für heute timo
los ist nur eine von 42 inseln mit
weniger als 1000 einwohnern die die
griechische regierung auf einen rutsch
durch impfte es wäre viel zu aufwändig
mehrfach impfstoff und personal zu
schicken
zudem ist gerade für diese kleinen
inseln der tourismus auch extrem wichtig
einige kilometer vom hauptort von rio
entfernt direkt am meer
frische pasta die zusammen mit ihrem
mann dimitrios ihre taverne und pension
auf die sie bereits seit 20 jahren
betreiben
anfragen für dieses jahr hat sie genug
ja ankunft am zwanzigster august abreise
am 5 septembers jaja das zimmer nummer
drei sie sind voller hoffnung dass ab 14
wie von der regierung versprochen die
tourismussaison beginnt und kinderlos
mit seiner komplett geimpften
bevölkerung zudem im vorteil ist
ich habe nichts mehr frei im august es
läuft sehr gut gott sei dank
das sind wirklich zeichen die
optimistische stimmen und da wir ja
jetzt eine kommune frei insel sind
können wir hoffen dass es so gut läuft
es geht nicht nur um sie im sommer
helfen ihre drei kinder und zuletzt
boten sie in der saison elf angestellten
arbeit auf der insel
die insel hat ja sonst nicht viel zu
bieten
futuristisch ist sie interessant wir
haben fantastische streng mit glasklaren
blauen wasser besonders für junge leute
gibt es kaum eine andere arbeit nur
etwas landwirtschaft und viehzucht dass
das geschäft mit dem tourismus läuft
garantiert tastatur blut das überleben
mit ihrem kleinen stoff waren laden sie
ist nach der ausbildung sogar aus athen
zurückgekehrt um hier zu leben um die
traditionellen e kunst weiterführen zu
können
[Musik]
ich bin in athen zur schule gegangen hab
da eine schneiderlehre gemacht und habe
in einer fabrik gearbeitet und dann
eines schönen morgens bin ich aufgewacht
und habe beschlossen zu kündigen und auf
einer insel zu leben
auch tavernen besitzerin weber sei dies
eine gute kundin
sie hat bei piano 100 traditionelle
rucksäcke nähen lassen als geschenk für
ihre gäste hier alles fertig bestückt
mit der aufschrift bitte schön dein
kleiner rucksack so schön sind die
perfekt sehr sehr hübsch und praktisch
wir kaufen alle in den gemüseläden und
in vier fünf supermärkten hier alle
produkte kaufen wir hier damit die
anderen unternehmer durchhalten können
und nicht fortgehen
am anderen ende der insel testet fotos
marina kies von natur verein mit anderen
freiwilligen einen wanderweg
damit urlauber die schroffe insel mit
ihren ungewöhnlichen geologischen
formationen erkunden können
stimmt die beschilderung noch ist der
weg begehbar damit die touristen einen
angenehmeren urlaub machen können und
damit es auch was interessantes gibt
wir machen das aber auch für uns selbst
überraschend erst es sind medizinerinnen
und mediziner die für die infektion auf
die insel gekommen sind
soll ich euch was über diesen felsens
kadir zählen ja gerne das phänomen
entstand durch erosion sandkörner und
wind die haben über jahrtausende die
untere weichere hälfte abgeschliffen
das medizinpersonal macht es möglich mit
ihrer infektion dass gäste wiederkommen
kann und sie wollen jetzt auch noch
selbst hier ferien machen genau das
machen wir wir sind schon dabei unseren
urlaub hier zu planen es ist echt
überwältigend zurück zum im zentrum der
insel noch stehen sie an
auch wenn es nicht mehr so viele sind
die auf ihre zweite dosis warten
wir warten noch auf vier personen diesen
namen ruf so die bitte mal an die laune
von kavernen besitzerin der basar die
nach dem impfen fast euphorisch frei und
schön wie es heißt ich bin froh und
fühle mich befreit von meinen ängsten
eine spritze auch für bürgermeister
constantinos ventur ist lässt sich von
der guten stimmung anstecken und will
einen corona sonderstatus für durch
geimpfte inseln wie kino los ich denke
für alle diese kleinen inseln bald soll
ja die tourismussaison beginnen und
zumindest die fremdenzimmer und lokale
müssen öffnen können
da sollten wir nicht pauschal wie der
rest griechenlands behandelt werden noch
gelten in griechenland quarantäne regeln
bei der einreise doch auf kino los
hoffen sie darauf dass die touristen
jetzt kommen können
zumindest auf ihre durch geimpfte insel
sie setzten nach der langen corona krise
auf eine saison ohne angst